o assunto é bom para desconstruir o
pensamento do cotidiano e falar pra
vocês compreendem no século 21 eu queria
contar um pouco da experiência que eu
tive durante a graduação
eu tive bastante dificuldade para
aprender a graduação e por um motivo bem
simples ea solução que eu achei que eu
queria passar para vocês aqui já demorou
para passar às pessoas que eu venho
reclamando que a gente ainda ensina como
se ensinava 300 anos que algumas coisas
podiam mudar
então o que eu queria passar para vocês
um pouco menos reclamação porque mais de
solução o que dá pra gente fazer hoje em
dia para aprender um pouco mais e o
problema que eu tive na graduação foi o
seguinte no último ano do ensino médio
eu já estava estudando para o vestibular
já estava focando no que a cair no
vestibular pra minha área de biológicas
então tinha algumas aulas que eu dava
uma cutilada eu dormir
o problema é que se você se acostuma
dormir uma aula de 45 minutos quando
você cai na graduação que a aula dura
quatro horas é impossível não dormir
duas horas o intervalo e duas horas de
aula eu vi um pescador da sala sabe que
fica tentando se não tá nem dormindo nem
acordado está todo mundo dando risada
para ver até onde vai a cabeça antes de
bater na mesa e eu tinha uma certa
dificuldade de perder uma parte da aula
especialmente quando é mauá longa por
isso mais uma coisa mudou
do meio para o fim da minha graduação do
meio para o fim da graduação eu comecei
a dar aulas em cursinho e depois que eu
comecei a dar aulas em cursinho mudou a
maneira como eu vi a água como eu vi a
minha graduação se antes eu dormi em
algumas aulas agora domingo todas
tudo porque eu falei pra vocês aqui o
cursinho no curso noturno eu dava aula
no cursinho popular que fica quatro
cidades de distância de são paulo eu sei
que a gente passou na frente lá hoje e e
eu dava aula à noite saía de lá ia pra
usp saia da usp pegar o metrô fazia a
última baldeação correndo de lá para a
zona sul de são paulo chegava em casa
uma da manhã e eu tinha que acordar no
outro dia 6 7 da manhã pra voltar pra
aula então não tinha jeito eu chegar
cansado mesmo com sono dormir mas eu
comecei a prestar muito mais atenção nas
aulas porque agora eu tinha alguém pra
quem contar o que eu estava aprendendo
é muito louco isso
antes havia aula se eu tivesse perdido
legal depois eu pegava uma anotação
agora eu tinha que dar uma aula daquilo
depois então tinha que saber o que
estavam falando se eu tivesse pescado na
aula eu tinha que pegar o lotação hora
que fosse da prova eu tinha que realizar
aquilo com muito mais atenção porque
depois eu ia falar isso pros meus alunos
melhor ainda se tivesse uma curiosidade
eu tenho a minha paixão era ouvir alguma
coisa legal em aula e poder repetir
depois na minha aula estava professor
gregório de de anatomia vegetal falou
uma vez que o tronco das árvores ele tem
uma atenção maior por dentro como se
fosse um concreto armado e é isso que
quando a árvore balança não deixa ela
quebrar e é por isso que vocês sabiam
que é por isso que um maço em ter o
mastro é melhor se ele for feito com um
tronco só de árvore do que foi feito com
várias tábuas juntas que ele está muito
mais resistente por causa da informação
também não é legal e eu tinha conta
essas coisas para os alunos
eu tinha esse anseio de ouvir uma coisa
legal repetir os outros aqui a paloma
esposa que há 15 anos é um penico de
curiosidade se houve alguma coisa legal
tem que contar pra ela e eu tava só
repetindo isso agora com os alunos mas
prestando muito mais atenção e aí quando
eu saí da graduação foi para a pós
graduação foi fazer mestrado eu não
podia mais da aula
só que inconscientemente eu continuo
repetindo essa vontade de ensinar alguma
coisa legal que estava aprendendo para
outras pessoas eu comecei a escrever um
blog que virou rainha vermelha que era
um blog de biologia virologia que eu
estava estudando na época eu podia
passar para as pessoas e eu tinha que
escrever lá o que eu estava aprendendo
porque era legal que estava aprendendo e
eu continue com essa sensação de que
quando você passa alguma coisa para as
pessoas
você aprende melhor não tem nada melhor
pra você sabe que você sabe não sabe do
que você trocar um slide na apresentação
e entra alguma coisa que não sabe bate
aquela que vazio no estômago você fala
meu deus eu não sei isso que eu estou
fazendo aqui eu sou uma fraude é ótimo
para você aprender o que não sabe
tem que revisar aquilo depois e quem
sabe chorar um pouquinho no banho vão
adoecer faz parte e e com o tempo eu
acabei partindo para drogas mais pesadas
além do do blog eu comecei a fazer vídeo
e agora toda semana tinha que falar
alguma coisa para as pessoas sobre
ciência
e essa paixão foi aumentando o que eu
não sabia na época é que essa sensação
que eu tinha de que ensinar outras
pessoas te ajuda a prender tenha um bom
embasamento ensinar de fato é uma das
melhores formas de aprender
pra quem quiser ver como tem um livro
que recomendo demais chama visitou o
enem do john howett que é um é uma meta
análise de meta análises
ele é um estudo de estudos que revisam
estudos que realizaram estudos sobre o
que funciona ou não em educação tudo que
der para testar em sala de aula que
testaram emitiram se muda a aprendizagem
dos alunos já foi revisado
uma outra revisão revisou as revisões e
ele revisou as revisões das revisões dos
estudos
aprendi muita coisa legal esse livro por
exemplo atividade fora de sala de aula
em escola não traz nada de novo com os
alunos em relação à aprendizagem pode
trazer a experiência de vida e outras
coisas mas para a matéria escola não
adianta muito férias de dois meses
atrasa o aprendizado que é uma beleza
você regride meses de aprendizado com as
férias o contributivo não sei o que você
pensa mas foi uma novidade pra mim ea
maioria das soluções que ele encontra
que realmente fazem a diferença em sala
de aula tem a ver com a interação do
professor com o aluno
mas isso fica para outra hora depois a
gente conversa
o ponto aqui quase tudo que ele encontra
só funciona dentro do ambiente da escola
só funciona com o professor com tutoria
e com alguma coisa assim
um dos poucos métodos que realmente
funciona de aprendizagem que dá pra
fazer em casa é ensinar outras pessoas e
som das poucas coisas que eles
encontraram o mais legal é o seguinte
não é que a gente não faz isso em sala
de aula porque não funciona
a gente não faz isso em sala de aula
porque o trabalho dos infernos se pegar
60 alunos numa sala principal onde eles
forem novos e colocar um para ensinar o
outro e tentar segurar essa turma então
a gente não usa isso em sala de aula
porque é uma limitação da sala de aula
mas essa limitação não existe mais no
mundo real
hoje a gente tem internet para isso a
gente tem como ensinar outras pessoas
por e mails e quando você faz isso você
realmente está
entendendo melhor o que você está
aprendendo especialmente se quando você
for ensinar alguém você avalia o que
você não sabe você avalia o que não está
claro sente falta do que você precisava
aprender eu precisava retomar percebe
quais são as suas deficiências
ensinar outras pessoas têm o melhor
benefício que é de ensinar a aprender
mais e aprender melhor
isso é uma coisa que faz uma diferença
enorme e que hoje em dia a gente tem a
solução a mão pra fazer
então se você quer aprender alguma coisa
nova que aprender a tocar um instrumento
andar de bicicleta uma outra língua
aprender a programar para a graduação
que memorizar melhor a matéria ensina
alguém faz um blog escreve texto é
editar artigos da wikipedia beneficia
bastante gente junto com você
se estiver com coragem disposição faz
vídeo o vídeo é legal porque se for uma
habilidade física que está aprendendo a
tocar um instrumento
você tem como transmitir isso melhor
para as pessoas e faz isso que você vai
ver o quanto você aprende mais
e o quanto você pode ter contato com
pessoas interessantes por fazer isso
inclusive se você está preocupado porque
aí eu comecei a aprender agora eu
aprendi que eu tô querendo ensinar para
as pessoas que eu vou ensinar para
alguém ficar tranquilo que pode ser até
melhor nessa situação tá no experimento
muito legal feito em glasgow em 2017 em
que eles pegaram alunos de graduação de
primeiro ano e docentes pesquisadores e
puseram as duas categorias para escrever
artigos de comunicação científica para
as pessoas o que o público queria mais
gostava era os artigos dos alunos de
graduação porque os alunos de graduação
usava uma linguagem mais simples eles
eram mais elaborados
eles incluíam mais detalhes que os
professores já assumiram que todo mundo
sabia então isso é até mais acessível
para as pessoas então se você tá só
aprendendo mal começou a ficar tranqüilo
porque o que você tem para ensinar
outras pessoas principalmente para quem
também está começando a aprender
às vezes é melhor do que a gente já tem
muita experiência anos de dedicação mas
não tem muita ginástica
as pessoas vão aproveitar o melhor é que
isso ainda te dá uma empolgação
são muito maior porque ao contrário de
fazer aquele trabalho de graduação de
aula que você vai dar a alguém vai
corrigir em ficar na gaveta e nunca mais
vai ver o que você ensina para as
pessoas principalmente pela internet
estará disponível para todo mundo para
sempre e outras pessoas podem ter
contato com aquilo
uma das melhores coisas que eu tive
dando aula foi pegar alunos de graduação
da licenciatura de biologia e colocar
eles para editar a wikipédia durante o
surto desliga de 2015
os alunos foram a desmentir um boato na
internet tirar uma reportagem errada do
ar e o artigo que eles editaram sobre
física na wikipedia
de lá pra cá teve mais de 220.000 acesso
não sei de nada que a gente faz de
atividade de escola de ensino que pode
ter um impacto tão grande nas pessoas
quanto bem simples de se falar olha vai
se entregar o que está fazendo
você vai entregar para as pessoas vai
ensinar outras pessoas que você está
aprendendo é muito mais empolgante isso
é muito mais motivador
tanto que é disso que eu vivo hoje eu
faço toda semana é justamente ensinar
outras pessoas
eu sempre tive essa sensação que eu
gostava de ensinar adorava ajudar alguém
estava de recuperação ou alguém que
estava em sala de aula estava atrasado
alguém que não tinha entendido que eu
tinha entendido eu adorava ir lá e
contar para aquela pessoa
o que eu tinha acabado de aprender e eu
continuo fazendo isso agora o tempo todo
contando com as pessoas o que eu acabei
de aprender porque as pessoas não sabem
quando elas vêem metodologia é que quem
está aprendendo com tecnologia não são
elas sou eu
é isso
[Aplausos]